le japon a résolument un pied dans le
futur à chaque jour son invention leader
en technologie le pays investit
massivement dans la recherche dans des
subventions pour que demain ce que l'on
voit ici et là soit la norme pour
soutenir les personnes âgées
pour l'instant ça reste souvent
inabordables mais l'urgence est bien là
car ce qui va très vite aussi c'est le
vieillissement de la population
ce village est un cas d'espèce avec sa
dizaine de centenaires et le tiers de la
population qui est plus de 60 ans cette
longévité est dû en partie enfin c'est
ce que l'on dit à ce fruit
le chic ou à sa spécialité locale très
acidulé aux vertus antioxydantes
yukiko nakagawa a dit qu'elle n'en
mangeaient déjà quand elle était dans le
ventre de sa mère
rien ne semble pouvoir la freiner en
plus de la coopérative agricole
elle est de tous les comités de toutes
les activités mémoires vives du village
de gimme donc on le voit quelques fois
le secret pour vivre vieux
c'est facile il faut toujours bavarder
avec les gens je suis bavarde et j'ai
confiance en moi
finalement il y a aussi les génétique
dit elle ma mère a vécu jusqu'à 97 ans
on est tous les parents ici et croit
également qu'un autre ingrédient pour
bien vieillir c'est de vivre en
communauté contenu lance-t-elle du
ppe-de être que l'on reçoit de l'état
[Musique]
sinon quand on voit des rouennais nos
images you may lose ça veut dire
s'entraider dans notre langue
on a line et on fait tout ensemble
construire les toits en paille par
exemple c'est très important
ici tout le monde connaît tout le monde
les gens de toutes les autres
communautés me connaissent bien que
autour des 80 s
des communautés qui décline petit à
petit nous évoquions je n'aurais jamais
imaginé gagner cette course à 69 ans
c'est l'âge de la retraite normalement
en fait le gouvernement veut que les
japonais travaillent le plus longtemps
possible pour retarder le versement des
prestations de retraite pour répondre à
l'explosion des coûts sociaux causés par
le vieillissement de la population et
pour pallier en partie la pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre et seconde carrière sont
également encouragées
et jk gîte à s'habituer à son nouvel
environnement
ancien pompier qu'il a troqué les
échelles pour les ordinateurs
il coordonne la sécurité du bâtiment le
montant de ma pension permet à ma
famille de vivre décemment
mais ce n'est vraiment pas le luxe dans
ce travail c'est une sorte de prime une
personne âgée sur trois est pauvre au
japon et jk gîte a dit qu'il a
recommencé à travailler car il avait
également peur de se sentir abandonnés
longtemps j'étais comme l'une des vices
d'une machine et quand j'étais détaché
de cette machine j'ai commencé à me
sentir très angoissée
j'avais besoin de me trouver une
nouvelle machine est une nécessité
sociale voire culturelles
au japon les vie bat au rythme de
rituels comme celui ci pour bien lancer
la journée il y a trente ans le
fondateur de cette société entendu à la
radio un poème qui faisait une fois
retraités tuner personnes ça l'a mis
très en colère et il a fondé cette
société à l'époque l'âge de la retraite
était encore à 55 ans il trouvait que
c'était un gaspillage d'intelligence
d'énergie d'expérience il ajoute que les
personnes âgées attire entre autres des
employeurs qui les considèrent comme de
la main d'oeuvre bon marché
les employés à qui on n'aurait pas à
payer un salaire trop élevé s'ils ont
fini de rembourser leur hypothèque ou de
payer les frais de scolarité de leurs
enfants qu'ils ont peut-être d épargne
et ont moins d'argent que les employés
plus jeunes l'an dernier le premier
ministre habib a qualifié le déclin
démographique de crise nationale c'était
positif
enfin ils reconnaissent l ampleur du
problème mais à son avis c'est encore
trop peu innovacom au cas où le
gouvernement est individuellement les
personnes âgées mais il n'améliore pas
la communauté le vivre ensemble et la
solidarité sur le colloque boots kacie
thomas être entouré d'édifices ce n'est
pas un rempart contre la solitude
avant c'était un peu plus animée
maintenant c'est un peu triste il ya
moins de gens il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'enfants mais de toute manière je ne
connais pas mes voisins quand centre
staquet le ici les bébé-boumeurs
japonais en rêvait de modernité le passé
note on aligne les meilleurs à l'aîné
mon voisin immédiat et marc soudainement
et son appartement reste toujours vide
mourir seul le codho kuchi sans que
personne ne s'en aperçoive
pendant un bon bout de temps avant que
l'odeur ne sonne l alarme
le phénomène prend de l'ampleur au pays
l'an dernier le nombre de décès a encore
surpassé le nombre de naissances au
japon moins d'un million de nouveaux
nids
si la tendance se maintient le pays
pourraient avoir perdu dans un siècle la
moitié sa population